[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando eu tinha 6 anos
eu era pequena ainda eu percebi que a
minha família ela conversava falando com
a boca e olhava e achava aquilo muito
estranho porque pra mim era muito
convencional conversar com as mãos
eu disse nossa eu acho que a minha
família tenha algum problema nós pra mim
é tão normal
comecei a ficar desconfiada disso mas eu
acreditava que eles tinham algum
problema
o tempo foi passando e eu aprendi
algumas coisas e acabei descobrindo o
que é que eu é que tinha problema
a deficiência estava comigo a minha
família não tinha problema algum eu é
que tinha o problema eu era surda
então os meus bisavós
eles eram primos de primeiro grau e
casaram e aí dos filhos que foram tendo
essas gerações que foram somando 39
surdos na família
nossa eles conseguiam se comunicar com
tranquilidade
não tínhamos nenhuma barreira que
impedia essa comunicação afinal de
contas já eram 39 surdos né
e eles eram a comunicação era feita
através de gestos caseiros sinais
combinados não era libras oficialmente
não quando eu tinha aproximadamente 11
anos eu eu sabia por exemplo que a minha
família
ela não conseguia explicar um detalhes
assim né
temos por exemplo como o sexualidade
eles explicavam coisas básicas através
dos gestos que eu mencionei pra vocês
é claro que eu tive algumas dificuldades
justamente eles não explicar em né
é desse jeito temas né relacionados a
drogas por exemplo ou outros assuntos
de acordo com a idade é nessa época
morava dentro da minha casa duas
mulheres uma minha mãe e outra que eu
acredito ser minha tia não tem muita
certeza disso
a minha mãe sempre estava junto comigo
a gente tinha um relacionamento muito
próximo de muita união e essa tia era
muito estranho assim parecia que ele
desprezava não tinha uma relação não
tinha uma relação de amor envolvido
apenas um contato com ela precisava de
algum favor como levar uma água levar o
seu cigarro levar um cafezinho entregar
alguma coisa pra ela apenas isso
a minha mãe não ela me levava pra todos
os lugares no hospital se precisasse na
escola fazia tarefas passava comigo
estávamos sempre juntas
após isso quando tinha aproximadamente
11 anos eu fui pra escola ea professora
pediu pra que a gente fizesse um cartão
porque o dia das mães estava se
aproximando a ok vamos fazer um desenho
e isso faça um desenho bonito pra
entregar pra mãe
ok vamos fazer e aí eu pintei fiz um
desenho bem bonito
fui até a professora e pedi pra ela
professora você poderia escrever alguma
frase em português porque eu não sei
escrever o português perfeito ainda você
poderia me ajudar a escrever pra mim no
quadro e aí eu copio no cartão ea
professora aceitou escreveu eu copiei no
cartão e eu perguntei quando devemos
entregar o cartão é a professora
respondeu no domingo e eu perguntei mas
quantos dias faltam para
domingo ea professora me respondeu
faltam três dias hoje é sexta feira
amanhã é sábado e aí no domingo você vai
entregar hoje você vai chegar em casa e
vai dormir aí passou pra sábado sábado
você dorme quando você acordar já é
domingo
ok combinado assim eu fui pra casa
estava super ansiosa feliz e empolgada
para entregar o cartão pra mãe na
sexta-feira eu dormi passou a sexta
feira acordei e perguntei pra mamãe
mamãe que dia hoje
hoje a domingo não hoje é sábado o
gessado de dormir novamente e acordei e
aí era domingo e eu estava super
empolgada
peguei o cartão e fui ao encontro dela
xaml desse mãe olha que ela pegou e eu
disse o que foi
você parece triste e eu não esperava
essa expressão esperavam expressão de
alegria e ela disse não é que você não
nasceu de mim e eu disse como assim
ela disse você é minha neta
eu sou a sua avó e disse como que já
comecei a chorar e eu disse à minha mãe
e ela apontou e disse à sua mãe é aquela
ali e aquela mulher estava deitada no
sofá fumando e quando eu olhei pra ela
olhou pra mim e fez assim que foi e eu
fiquei chocada
chorando muito e eu disse eu não quero
que ela seja minha mãe eu não quero não
aceito isso eu quero que você continue
sendo minha mãe a minha voz não
conseguia me responder nada e eu chorava
muito desesperadamente botei aquele
cartão em si
a mesa e sair correndo chorando
desesperadamente foi muito sofrido
essa foi uma história que eu consegui
superar
mas que marcou muito a minha vida a
minha família eu não tinha nenhuma
barreira né
eu conseguia conversar e me comunicar
naturalmente mans
eu percebia que fora do ambiente
familiar em comunicação com os ouvintes
eu não conseguia me comunicar fora da
minha família na família
ok era gostoso eu tinha aquele conforto
aquela segurança e fora eu sentia isso
eu percebi essa dificuldade
então eu comecei a namorar muito cedo
com 14 anos e avó é o nome explicável
por exemplo né como cuidar de mim como
não ficar grávida né como evitar uma
gravidez
então eu ficava junto comigo eu ia no
cinema com meu namorado ela é junto a
gente no restaurante ela ia junto nós
namorávamos a3 basicamente então quando
a gente sentava e ficava namorado do
lado e avó do outro e se eu quisesse dar
um beijão por exemplo a minha avó dar
uma cutucada e fazia nã que feio
aí a gente dava sons beijinhos assim só
há a mãe do meu namorado
ela me chamou um dia e me explicou
algumas coisas né relacionadas à
sexualidade e perguntou se eu sabia e eu
disse não não sei nada disso
como assim e ela me explicou nem a
respeito de camisinha anticoncepcionais
mas temas relacionados à sexualidade né
não
tinha essa informação eu era inocente
mesmo nesse sentido
e aí a minha avó por exemplo ela só me
avisava se você ficar grávida eu te boto
na rua você vai dormir na rua vai passar
fome vai ser problema seu e eu ficava em
choque com aquilo né
eu entendo a minha avó ela não me
explicavam as coisas
claro ela tinha vergonha era uma questão
tradicional muito forte né de poodle né
pra época que ela viveu
eu não o culpo
eu acho que ela pensava que se ela não
falasse nada eu não ia fazer nada
tadinha da vovó né
assim o tempo foi passando e eu fui me
desenvolvendo fui é claro aprendendo
coisas novas tendo novas experiências
fui me desenvolvendo me formei iniciei
minha vida profissional
nessa época eu era professora
eu comecei a perceber que um aluno me
olhava diferente
ele era ouvinte e aí a gente começou a
se olhar
começamos a namorar a ele se esforçou
bastante estudava bastante e gostava
muito de me ajudar em qualquer lugar que
eu ia lá ele me ajudava
depois a gente casou e aí nós dois
combinamos que a gente queria engravidar
porque eu queria muito mostrar pra minha
avó que eu era capaz que eu tinha
conseguido me desenvolver que eu tinha
entendido tudo que ela me ensinou né que
eu me desenvolvi me formei casey tudo
certinho como ela havia orientado e
agora eu gostaria de ter um filho pra
mostrar pra ela e eu comecei a tentar
engravidar e eu não conseguia
e aí a avó acabou falecendo
tudo bem fazer o quê
e aí eu resolvi esquecer esse assunto
dois anos depois eu descobri que estava
grávida
foi o momento certo
foi deus que mandou no momento certo
quando minha filha nasceu o meu marido
ele me ajudou muito nesse sentido
lutas e tudo porque o sintep muitos
profissionais estavam ocupados
e aqui em blumenau também tem poucos
profissionais então meu marido sempre me
acompanhava me apoiava muito nesse
sentido
e aí no nascimento então da minha filha
linda fofa
eu comecei a me preocupar
será que a minha filha surda
eu tinha muita preocupação em relação a
isso não é uma questão de preconceito
era muito sofrimento eu passei muito
sofrimento muita dificuldade com a minha
experiência de vida não tinha escola
100% bilingue especial para surdos não
tinha
e a gente foi ao médico e descobriu que
ela era ouvinte
eu agradeci muito a deus eu fiquei muito
feliz
não é uma questão de preconceito é uma
questão de experiência de vida
eu sabia a minha experiência de vida e
não queria isso para minha filha e por
isso agradecer muito a deus ea minha
filha foi crescendo e quando eu queria
falar alguma coisa que ela fez errado
por exemplo brigar com ela né que ela
fazia o que fechava os olhos e não me
olhava ficava assim como é que eu ia
fazer para dar bronca nela será que
chacoalhava não abraçava e enchia de
beijo com aquela fofura
aí ela abriu os olhos e ria para mim e
as estratégias foram se desenvolvendo ao
longo do tempo e aí eu explicar à filha
precisa olhar pra mim para eu conseguir
falar contigo e assim ela foi crescendo
quando ela tinha três anos ela correu e
caiu e ela chorou muito gritava gritava
e é claro eu não ouvi estava lavando a
louça bem tranquila
e ela veio chorando
minha direção eu não olhei certo eu
estava lavando a louça
aí ela me chamou e quando eu virei o
disse o que foi e ela olha que me
machuquei o bei você nem olhou pra mim
com três anos
imaginem vocês choro o filho desculpa eu
disse a filha
o meu ouvido quebrou e ele não consegue
te ouvir e ouvir que ela mim o olhou
assim e aí eu pensei olha só vira pra lá
vira pra lá ela virou eu gritei e ela se
assustou
aí quando ela virou eu falei viu você
escuta
agora pega aí eu vou olhar para lá e
você copia e faz a mesma coisa e ela
gritou gritou eu não ouvi
aí ela me cutucou eu virei pra ela e nós
duas nos olhamos e ela com a expressão
estranha
adivinhe o que a minha filha fez saiu de
mansinho e eu fiquei observando que que
ela vai fazer daqui a pouco voltou ela
quando eu vi foi muito engraçado
ela tinha um parafuso e aí ela disse
vamos arrumar o seu ouvido tadinha
brincar brincar ela dizia ai eu estava
em pé me abaixei e ela disse vamos
arrumar aqui ó
vamos arrumar mas não dá aí eu peguei o
parafuso
joguei o parafuso longe aí ela viu e eu
falei 'não filha não dá para arrumar e
eu lembro que ela ficou me olhando assim
é com aquela expressão eu disse oh meu
ouvido está estragado mas não da adi a
roma
quando você precisar me chamar você tem
que encostar na mãe
e aí quando ela tinha 5
anos ela entendeu de verdade que ela
tinha uma mãe surda
a gente já conseguia se comunicar um
pouco e aí por exemplo quando ela me
falava uma palavra eu não entendia o que
era aquela palavra e daí a gente ficava
naquela situação angustiante e eu disse
para você chamar o seu pai
aí eu chamei o pai dela na webcam aí
mostrei ela falou com ele e eu vi ele me
explicou neco que quer a palavra ea
minha filha viu aquela dinâmica né viu o
é
então se eu falo com meu pai o pai
interpreta para ela ele traduz ela
começou ela entendeu que ela podia fazer
isso também eu nunca obriguei ela nada e
assim ela começou a me ajudar
então o meu desejo é o mesmo desejo que
de outras mães certo vocês também são
mães têm mães aí o meu desejo não é
diferente do desejo de vocês é igual é
principalmente o que eu quero que a
minha filha se desenvolva eu quero que
ela aprenda que ela tenha conhecimento
de mundo que entenda que nós temos
características diferentes independente
de cor diz e ouvintes e surdos são
muitas características que ela não tenha
preconceito que tenha oportunidades
iguais para todas as pessoas que ela
viva num mundo assim especial é isso que
eu quero pra ela
por isso eu digo que é a mesma coisa que
eu acredito que vocês querem
obrigada
[Aplausos]
eu vi várias mamães assim pensando nossa
cidade